people with darker complexions have
always struggled with having good
lighting every single yearbook photo of
mine has been terribly shot since I was
a kid I always show up as too dark or
shiny
cause if you love me you love all of me
[Music]
everything the light
that's a real ad
I think it's a party
that's not oh
baby give me life touches
[Music]
over my mind don't you be afraid
[Music]
and if you love me you love all of me
or none of me at all
if if it's a parody that's a real ad
it's well done it's a real ad but that's
listen all those pictures that you'll
you would you was too dark to be in
everybody was shot it was it was bad for
everybody just we just didn't see us
right at some point you have to
understand lighting
the girl that was standing there was
there and I'm like you're in a Hall
that's not understanding how cameras
work that's it
that's that's it the moral you put that
[ __ ] you put that [ __ ] on automatic and
you shoot pictures
the moral of this story if you want a
good picture [ __ ] go outside
well like bad Barbie they say catch me
outside how about that and you know what
because that's all this was this
person's talking about the new pixel the
only difference between the beginning
pictures like other pictures the [ __ ]
outside that's it the pictures that are
more like no but the pixel catchers
captures the light
I and I know yeah it's been it's been a
problem for black people when you take
pictures and everything and stuff it's
just people applying
people appoint people not understanding
[ __ ] cameras that's it that's what it
is cameras were [ __ ] basic and [ __ ]
and that's it it was like it's sad I
don't know what they were thinking with
this one the one of the pictures was
this girl she was like kind of outside
but instead of being in the the the
daylight she was in the shadowed area of
the building and then her the daylight
was behind her of course you're gonna be
underexposed let me guess this ad came
out on black in black history month no
well technically Super Bowl
since February is it let us know in the
comments below if you think the Super
Bowl's in February don't Google it you
piece of [ __ ]
February this
um
play that [ __ ] back let me guess this ad
came out on black in black history month
Google you ain't [ __ ] for this one
you said to yourself this uh
how can we get [ __ ]
yeah super at at the Super Bowl wow you
know what you know the thing I noticed
about ads that I feel like is such a
[ __ ] hottie it's such a marketing
gimmick because whenever they do these
ads you ever notice like
in terms of like the racial component
they try to get like one lgbtq couple
one trains couple one lesbian couple one
gay young kids bucktooth I just think
it's so interesting with like the stuff
that they go for such an emphasis on
diversity for the thing it's like
ingrained in every marketing and the
Playbook they didn't they didn't see how
cringe this was his cringe this is that
thing that I would that we've talked
about before where it's like diversity
for the sake of a diversity often is
just [ __ ] crazy it's just a handout
looking thing right I really miss those
days when people
didn't care about diversity and didn't
care at I don't mind if people care
about it I just think it's weird to lead
with that do you get what I'm saying if
the content is garbage who cares if it's
diverse it's just diversity of trash
sometimes I get what I'm saying
sometimes when people didn't care about
diversity it's just like when you care
too much it's still it still sounds fake
I I really sometimes I miss those days
when people were out of touch really out
of touch yeah and the issue is not that
you have an all-black cast I don't I
don't Flinch when I see I don't think
like oh my God diversity because I grew
up on the fresh prince I grew up on the
Jamie Foxx Show right these were all
black casts and I enjoyed it and I
didn't sit there thinking like oh this
but sometimes just the way that they go
about the whole process is crunchy as
hell you could tell they just sprinkled
in the character they made them black or
whatever because
it's efficient not because they wanted
to write a good story you get what I'm
saying yeah maybe maybe I'm
black characters or black cats cat it
never felt like
something they were purposefully trying
to enforce or to push for diversity
purposes now it's really just not with
Virgin yes I really means I really miss
those I miss those publicity
come on I'll show you some of my
favorite spots around Australia
Bridge Stop the fridge
I couldn't taste man let's talk to some
real cheese experts your Maine [ __ ]
cheese expert Peter say what I mean you
need income cheese for 60 years or more
60 years come on all around Australia
people love that great [ __ ] taste
say cheese
[Applause]
you got to be honest
if you gotta be honest let's be out of
touch but now you're trying to merge the
signal and it's as cringy as this
I don't know if it does it for you for
me when I see ads like these it makes me
never want to buy the product
all right I Google yeah yeah because
I've never been a mac person I hate
Apple my whole life with the deepest
part of my fiber I hate the whole yes
yes but I see an ad like this I'm like
hey yeah no you know slate labor in
India let's go [ __ ] give me my iPhone
wow you know what I'm saying yeah why
you get that [ __ ] cheese yay exactly
whatever Steve Jobs what you got for me
bro he did yeah lizzo got her back she
got her back that's for sure and that
was an easy bag yeah thousand easy bags
so
shout outs to you Liz let us know what
you guys think in the comments about
Jesus Christ we should let us know what
you guys think yeah the whole the whole
sometimes I feel like when I see these
commercials I'm like come on who you
trying to appeal to with this what did
you do what is you doing when you guys
were casting this where you got like one
Indian person one young yeah but you
know what I mean you really straight up
check boxes that's what you did yeah
when you did that thing you got what to
be fair to them to be fair to them if
I'm seeing Devil's Advocate this is
technically an ad to show the Mosaic of
black folks yeah so maybe showing them
in all their different genders
expression all that stuff is part of the
marketing which is fine in this instance
I'll give much more leeway than I would
other people you know what I'm saying
but a lot of these other ads like
they've got one Asian guy one black
person like the Power Rangers
when where when when June comes
everybody's in the rainbow flag and I'm
like
and the Black is Black
hey actually our arrows got to hold the
L for that one yeah they do yeah because
it would have been funny to have they
should have put a black man being the
the white one just to flip it up yeah
white power or maybe it's just like the
black man saying because they love white
women yeah yeah exactly anyways let us
know what you got we gotta hold it up
for that one yeah but to be fair we also
thought Power Rangers is kind of corny
Fair we did it was it was we knew it was
corny yes entertaining but corny yes but
it was we just touched it on this like
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below do you guys agree or
disagree